la guerre au Kosovo ce n'est pas le pied
les enfants l'ont bien compris faudrait
qu'ils entam des nouvelles négociations
avec Paris et puis tout ça comme ça ça
éviterai des victimes ben qu' on rien
fait par exemple ceux qui qu' on pas
voté pour le président du Kosovo et qui
est lui qui a qui veut pas faire signer
le pacte et ben c'est pas de leur faute
et puis nous on leur tire dessus donc ce
serait bien que le président pense un
peu à ça ce serait mieux de faire des
négociations plutôt que de plutôt que de
travailler avec les armes fa moins de
mort tu penses qu'on peut faire la paix
bah c'est un petit peu difficile à dire
mais oui si on si on le veut ben on le
peut ça fait des morts ça dépend on
dépense de l'argent mais c'est pas
l'argent qui compte mais ça fait des
morts ça fait des épidémies ça fait de
tout c'est pas bien la tu trouvve que
c'est idiot parce que ils disent que
c'est ça leur appartient alors que ça
leur appartient pas du tout ils veulent
les détruire alors que ils ont rien fait
ils ont rien demandé ils ont rien fait
contre eux